Hi, guys. Welcome back to our
Business English series.
Let's jump straight back in with the
rest of our tips for improving delegation.
Trust your team. Now, I
know some of you are screaming
at me through the screen right
now, 'but they need to earn my trust'.
And you are right. But remember,
you have all already been
getting used to delegation. We have
started small. We have handed
over tasks to people who have
the skill set, and we started to
diversify the skill set of our
different team members too.
Have faith in them. You cannot
earn trust or build trust if you do
not allow them the opportunity
to do so.
We're breaking down the language. Yeah, yeah.
Today we're looking at the phrase 'getting used to',
not to be confused with
'used to' for past habits.
Here, we are adding the phrase
'to get' or 'to be' in front of it,
and it has a similar meaning to
'become familiar with something'.
For example, we are getting used
to handing over tasks. We do
it a little bit, a little bit,
a little bit, until this practice
becomes normal and comfortable
and easier for us. Since Covid,
many of us have started going
back to the office for work,
so we are getting used to commuting again.
We've broken down the language.
Now, just because you have faith in your team
and you are trusting them, doesn't
mean that you can simply check out.
Work.
I'm delegating.
Offer support. Have open channels of
communication and make sure that you clearly
communicate goals and deadlines
to your team.
Have an open door policy.
And remember, now that you
have gotten used to offloading
those extra tasks, you should have
more free time to help manage
your team and their specific needs.
Remember guys, there is no such thing as I in team.
I hope that you enjoyed our series
and are practising and improving
your delegation skills at work or
at home. If you haven't already,
please feel free to subscribe
to our channel by clicking on
the links below. I will
see you next time.